[Musique]
vous voyez à mes côtés je n'ai pas
isabelle aujourd'hui mais isabelle n'est
pas très loin vous allez voir on va
aller la retrouver dans quelques
instants
aujourd'hui nous allons parler d'une
manifestation humaine qui s'appelle le
racisme et je le dis parce que cette
manifestation ne devrait pas exister ce
mot n'aurait jamais dû être inventés et
ceux qui en sont victimes sont les
personnes assises et très souvent et les
personnes autochtones
alors pourquoi est ce que c'est le cas
comment est-ce qu'on peut changer les
choses c'est ce dont nous allons
discuter au cours des prochaines minutes
avec nos invités alors qu'isabelle n'est
pas à côté je vous le disais mais c'est
aux médias la rivière bonjour oui dia
oui oui dia je vais prendre mes lunettes
je vais prendre l'a fait parce que j'ai
tellement de choses à dire sur vous vous
êtes éducatrice en droits humains et
droits des peuples autochtones
vous êtes la cofondatrice de mika n'a
donc ça nos organismes qui veut
sensibiliser sur les réalités
autochtones c'est bien ça vous êtes à
coup une initiatrice de la mobilisation
québécoise du mouvement aille d'or noir
avec mélissa mollen dupuis vous est
ambassadrice de la conscience d'amnistié
internationale vous êtes aux tris et
vous êtes cinéaste et j'ajouterais vous
êtes une fière anishnabe originaire de
la communauté de timiskaming en
abitibi-témiscamingue parfait maintenant
en skaï peut nous avons maïté labrecque
saganash bonjour maïté merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avant d'aller plus loin vous
êtes louer ou là physiquement en ce
moment d'accord alors ouais swan
hippiques qui est votre communauté
d'origine parce que vous êtes une fière
cris n'est ce pas originaire donc de la
communauté de waswanipi situés en ue
witschi baie james donc dans le nord du
québec
maïté vous êtes technicienne aux
communications du conseil de la santé
crise est bien ça et vous êtes
chroniqueuse pour le journal métro on a
un petit son qui nous arrive attendez on
va le
laisser partir voilà alors merci maïté
d'être là et puis nous allons aller à
québec c'est là que se trouve notre
collègue chroniqueuse également
ethnologue isabelle picard bonjour
isabelle vous êtes l'arroseur oui voilà
alors voilà oui je vous vois on va le
rappeler vous êtes une fière wendat
originaire de wayne d'accueil dans la
région de québec
et c'est justement à québec que vous
êtes aujourd'hui
alors j'ai intitulé cette émission-là
arrose sur le racisme envers les
autochtones parce qu'on est même si on
est en 2020 vous êtes encore toutes les
trois victimes de racisme
est-ce qu'on pourrait y aller avec des
exemples concrets ce que vous pourriez
nous expliquer des situations dans
lesquelles vous en faites des situations
que vous avez vécu dans lesquelles vous
étiez impliqués et où vous avez senti du
racisme envers vous on va commencer à
lekhwiya
ouais mais moi j'aimerais quand même
commencé par dire que je suis quand même
privilégié parce que j'ai ce qu'on
appelle le privilège de passe de la
pensée je pense en anglais donc je n'ai
pas nécessairement vivent désormais
expliquer ce que c'est
en fait c'est que je peux pas assez pour
une place une personne blanche houlette
les gens pour pas nécessairement savoir
tout de suite une personne autochtone et
ça ça me quand même éviter certaines
situations de racisme que certains
confrères au concert la docteure ne
peuvent avoir vécu notamment parce que
les gens de suite les ont identifiés
comme autochtone que ce soit par la
couleur de la peau un accent qui parle
en français la même chose si pour
l'accent dont j'aimerais quand même
enseigne et qui comme différents types
de raciste qui vécut puis que même entre
autochtone j'ai vécu quand même
différemment d'une personne à l'autre
mais tout ce que je peux dire dans mon
entourage sait que le racisme envers les
autochtones se manifestent vraiment de
différentes manières que ce soit
plus globalement la discrimation camp
qui cherchent un logement dans l'emploi
l'instance de représentation des enfants
autochtones dans les services de
protection d'achat neuf on a vu aussi
dernièrement la sous-représentation des
femmes autochtones encore dans le
dossier donc c'est vraiment et de
peut-être plus haut niveau systémique de
queue
qu'on parle dans ces cas ci met donc en
fait du documentaire briser les codes
d'iliad est de démontrer aussi que le
racisme se manifestent vraiment aussi de
manière c'est pas toujours de manière
décomplexée mais de manière plus subtile
oui c'est ce qui va venir par exemple à
fêter notre vie quotidienne a aussi par
exemple
moi même je peux je peux je l'aï vécu
quand même avec la reprise de devoir
comme adapter mon comportement
certains - justin à cause de la boum
devant c'est amusant parce qu'on en n'a
pas encore lâché et on va en parler dans
quelques instants on va d'abord écouté
l'expérience ou les expériences qu
aurait vécu maïté des expériences de
racisme à votre encontre maïté la même
chose mais bon moi j'habite est de 200
turbin où il ya beaucoup d'autochtones
donc c'est parfois je me fais identifier
puis ça peut prendre ça peut prendre
plusieurs formes des fois bon je peux me
faire suivre dans un commerce
des fois il ya des gens qui est bon qui
peut se passer outre et indienne mais ça
peut aussi prendre des formes plus
systémique comme l'ont mentionné
williams puis moi bonjour j'ai beaucoup
j'ai beaucoup vécu de bons écrivains au
journal métro aussi bon j'ai reçu
beaucoup de commentaires je pense j'ai
été exposé en étant une jeune femme
autochtone je pense j'ai exposés à
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle des trolls
mais on part mais plus d'opposition des
gens qui s'amusaient à morceler sur les
réseaux sociaux puis sortait des
désastres à 6 ou bon dire des choses
comme au mec est quand même belle pour
une indienne ailleurs oui donc donc
comme le mentionnait oui diarra c'est ça
prend plusieurs formes
moi je pense que c'est bouffe c'est
beaucoup cette marie isabelle de votre
côté je vous pose la question aussi
est-ce que vous avez été victime de
racisme
en tant que femme autochtone oui oui
absolument ça m'est arrivé déjà dans le
passé les premières fois aux règles
doivent avoir envie retrait
c'était juste après la crise d'oka donc
quand je suis revenu à l'école
secondaire j'étais en secondaire 2 et là
j'ai eu le droit à une panoplie de bon
ton père vendu des cigarettes de tous
les stéréotypes le qu'on peut avoir à
propos à des autochtones tu vas tu nous
faire une barricade bon des trucs comme
ça je les ai à peu près tout entendu de
monnaie la plus récente je dirais que un
petit il ya quatre ans j'ai acheté une
maison à montréal et je la raconte
souvent cette anecdote là mais je pense
qu'on parle de petites choses ça
s'inscrit à l'intérieur de ça la dame
qui me vendait la maison une québécoise
me demandez pas ce que je fais un peu
comme me dit ah je peux également pas
assez pour une blanche était pas
certaine elle a discuté italienne et
j'ai dit non je ne suis pas italienne je
suis autochtone et elle m'a répondu bah
écoute c'est peut-être mieux de paul
mentionné au voisin que tu es autochtone
donc ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
entendu et on a souvent également
surveiller ma consommation d'alcool ça
m'est déjà arrivé j'étais célibataire je
rencontrais des hommes et puis là au
bout de deux verres ils vérifiaient les
dons qui me posaient des questions
là-dessus on part avec certains
stéréotypes certains préjugés je pense
comme comme autochtone fait qu'il ya
tellement d'ignorance et je pense que le
racisme est souvent lié aussi à
l'ignorance ou izia
ben oui totalement c'est en fait c'est
une des causes principales du racisme
c'est justement la méconnaissance ou est
la peur de l'étranger
quand on est différent habituellement
bon s'inquiète c'est un étranger entre
guillemets je le dis la peur de
l'étranger mais aussi de laisser en
partie l'ignorance oui oui tout à fait
tout à fait et puis en fait encore
aujourd'hui mais il ya quand même une un
taux de prise de conscience collective
pas d'apport de société québécoise
envers les questions autochtones mais il
ya encore beaucoup de chemin à faire
puis justement ce matin je disais
l'histoire d'une jeune attikameks qui
joue en équipe qui est victimes
quotidiennement de propos racistes qui
avait joué dans d'autres villes dans des
game de hockey
il ya encore beaucoup de et c'est ça
m'amène justement à ce documentaire
briser le code de fabrice ville un
documentaire qui a été diffusée sur télé
québec au cours des derniers jours le
jeudi soir je pense ou mercredi soir le
29 ou et en 1031 et donc qui met en
scène quatre personnes trois personnes
racisées donc d'ailleurs je pense
qu'elles sont toutes nées au québec mais
de parents venus d'ailleurs elles ont un
accent aux différents où elles ont un
look différent et donc elles sont on les
considère comme des étrangers un des
personnes venues d'ailleurs alors
qu'elles sont vraiment né ici et une
personnes autochtones
alexandre volant qui vient de pessamit
tu est donc lui est autochtone et qui
vit lui aussi ce racisme latent qu'il
peut rencontrer dans la rue à l'école
avec n'importe où finalement parce que
c'est ça le racisme il est partout
nessma oui tout à fait puis ben c'est ça
qu'est ce qu'on a vu dans fait plus
spécifiquement ou que d'alexandre dans
le grand documentaire ceci est bien fait
lui
c'est ça y est partie de la communauté
de pessamit pour aller vu la forêt à ce
moment là qu'a commencé à deux le pays
ces mécanismes de défense
alors ça c'est pour ça que le
documentaire s'appelle briser le code
parce qu'il lui même
je pense aujourd'hui essaye de briser ce
code
alors j'avais trouvé une définition
intéressante de briser le code c'est
amener les personnes racisées ou
autochtone à adopter des attitudes et
comportements pour se fondre à la
majorité est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous avez déjà fait oui dia briser
le colloque ou au contraire est-ce que
vous êtes déjà entrée dans le code vous
avez suivi le code
ouais ben en fait avant même que
j'appris on hamm est un bourg ce cas
c'est le capi ces mécanismes de défense
de mais oui en repensant je pars jamais
vraiment fait absolue dans ma vie et
aussi parce que comme je parlais tantôt
avec mon privilège de passes blanc c'est
plus facile pour moi de cacher que je
suis autochtone donc c'est par exemple
déjà arrivé que je sois dans un
covoiturage maintenant avec amigo
express puis là cette journée là ça me
tente pas vraiment de de faire un cours
autochtones enfin engagé fait que l'eau
quand les gens me demandent à william
parce que ça c'est à travers mon prénom
c'est donc un cdi ou d'un cdd ça veut
dire quoi c'était une origine
particulière puis à certains moments
c'est ça j'ai déjà dit caché que c'était
un prénom anishnabe parce que je ne
supportais pas de commencer à expliquer
pendant tout le long du trajet les
réalités autochtones puis parce que
c'est quand même épuisant de porter sur
ses épaules de l'éducation que la
sensibilisation et
quotidienne souligne le docteur pascal
comme cette entame encore de l'ignorance
et de méconnaissance
donc oui j'ai comme réalisé que qui a eu
plusieurs situations comme ça en tout
cas vraiment j'ai utilisé le code
aujourd'hui je suis plus conscient
depuis donc je sais ce que d'y penser ça
qu'on essaie de le briser mais en même
temps c'est pas le rehaussement des gens
qui utilisent le code de briser les
idées bas les gens qui font des
commentaires les gens qui ont des propos
être un peu plus conscients de ce qu'ils
disent maïté maïté est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu à emprunter le code là pour
passer inaperçus ou ne pas trop vous
faire remarquer absolument je pense que
ça le pré salé pris forme surtout dans
les prises de position que j'avais dont
je voulais pas je voulais pas faire trop
de remous puis je voulais faire
certaines choses que dont il sortait ce
sujet sur lequel j'écris que ça passe
moins bien donc devenu une forme aussi
de toute censure avec c'est donc il ya
des journées où ça me tente pas de
recevoir des tweets mais charlier
d'aujourd'hui où ça me va pas
roddick pour avec des insultes donc oui
non absolument il faut ni même encore
aujourd'hui des fois où ce que
j'aimerais écrire sur certains sujets
mais je ne peux pas donc non pied
absolument puis je pense que je pense
que tout le monde
aussi certaines voies de service à la
clientèle russie aujourd'hui j'habite
dans ma communauté donc certains
bouillon de certains soins qu'on utilise
veille certaines certaines expressions
qu'on est habitué à certaines actions
aussi qu'on a un contenu en anglais dans
la réserve mais que je devais adopter
que je n'adopte pas quand je suis à la
télévision quand je suis vous téléphone
un appel important qu'en juin entrevue
mais je pense que c'est ce code le sam
bon de travailler aussi dans un
institution qui écrit avec des avec
d'autres et je pense que ça m'a aidé
aussi à
a un peu brisé cette fois dans ma vie
personnelle parce que je travaille avec
mes pairs je travaille pour mon père
aussi
et donc j'ai pas besoin d'eux j'ai pas
besoin de plaire à qui compte en fait je
travaille juste pour ma communauté du
travail de formation et isabelle de
votre côté est ce que vous même vous
avez endossé le code pour passer
inaperçu oh oui ah oui absolument
surtout plus jeune je dirais pour des
emplois en particulier tu étais pas j'ai
travaillé autant des organisations
autochtones que dans des non autochtone
et je me suis aperçu rapidement que je
ne fonctionnait pas de la même manière
quand je travaillais pour la ville de
montréal par exemple ou pour un
gouvernement exclut y
il ya des manières de faire qui était
qui étaient différentes et aussi
beaucoup dans l'umoa moi c'est dans
l'humour que je vois mon humour est
différent quand je suis entouré de
personnes autochtones que quand je veux
être à l'extérieur on dirait que quand
nous notre humour autochtone et très on
est beaucoup dans l'autodérision on est
on rit un peu des autres mais c'est pas
méchant une manière de le faire qui est
qui et bienveillante sa l'extérieur ça
passe moins bien donc dans mon réseau
social qui est non autochtone
aussi je vais changer ça puisqu'elle
m'adapter finalement au code
oui lors du dépôt du rapport vient donc
cette grande commission qui a été tenu
au québec au cours des deux dernières
années qui a été déposée en septembre
dernier le juge vient parlait de
discrimination il parlait pas de racisme
est en fait ghislain picard le chef de
la pnq est la maman données du avait dit
regarder mais mettons les bons mots sur
les bonnes affaires il est question
aussi de racisme et dans la société
qu'elle soit québécoises ou canadiennes
on parle beaucoup de raciste de racisme
systémique alors isabelle je me tourne
vers vous le racisme systémique
c'est quoi exactement mais en fait si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi je pense que c'est
le système tout ce qui compose le
système ses lois ses politiques dans ces
programmes la manière dont il est il a
été bâti même ses fondements qui vont
faire en sorte que
un groupe donné soit par bon niveau de
sa race nommément va être traité à part
va être traité en particulier évidemment
on pense aux autochtones dans un cas
comme celui là entre autres la loi sont
les indiens va faire en sorte que les
autochtones vont être traitées et tout
ce qu'ils savent tout ce qui en découle
bien sûr d'en faire en sorte que les
autochtones doit avoir une place à part
dans la société
donc en lien avec cette loi donne
notamment
ok alors on pour y revenir au rapport
vient justement lors de la commission
vient il y avait là d'observatrice
indépendante fannie lafontaine qui en
avait parlé du racisme elle même a été
une des premières je pense à aborder ce
thème là oui tout à fait en fait madame
la fontaine c'est en 2016 en novembre
2016 qu'elle a déposé son premier
rapport on se souvient qu'elle était
observatrice indépendante dans le cadre
de l'enfer valda avec les policiers et
elle avait nommé ça a été la première à
nommer les choses c'est à dire oui j'ai
pu observer qu'il y avait une culture de
racisme systémique au niveau des corps
policiers plus précisément peut-être à
val-d'or et on fait le rapport vient il
venu un peu confirmé bien qu'il ait
parlé davantage de discriminations mais
il ya quand même également avec bon les
témoignages le cul pendant la commission
il a pu voir qu'il y avait quand même
une culture de discrimination à tout le
moins systémique le haut niveau du
gouvernement québécois
voilà donc on n'ose prononcer le mot
maintenant et pourtant les exemples de
racisme qui soit systémique ou autres
envers les autochtones
on en voit pratiquement tous les jours
bon j'exagère parce qu'ils ne sont pas
dans les médias tous les jours mais
j'imagine que j'exagère pas parce que
dans la réalité les autochtones les les
îles les inuit qu'il soit inuit qu'il
soit première nation ou métis le vivent
chacun à leur manière un peu tous les
jours n'est ce pas isabelle oui oui tout
à fait mais en faire quand on parle de
racisme souvent on s'imagine il ya des
gens qui vont s'imaginer automatiquement
quand on parle d' antisémitisme ou de
crimes haineux ou quelque chose de
violent mais le racisme ça peut être
vous raciste
dinner donc du racisme de tous les jours
des petites choses qui va partir de
préjugés et de stéréotypes
ça peut être la peur de l'autre ça peut
être aussi vous savez la colonisation a
été basée ça c'est quand même assez
intéressant mais c'est basé sur le fait
qu' il ya un peuple qui est supérieur à
l'autre et donc quand les européens sont
arrivés ici bâillon nie et le peuplement
déjà existants sur le territoire
donc c'est très rare chief fait partie
aussi c'est une forme de racisme
également bien sûr la n va être un des
facteurs l'intolérance également va être
un des facteurs le qui vont amener du
racisme donc le racisme s'est inscrit
aussi pour seulement dans les grandes
choses mais aussi dans les petites
choses du quotidien
on pourrait donner des exemples vous
dire vous en avez donné avant qu'on
entre en nom de la vous m'avez parlé d'
un exemple assez concret merci un jeune
hockeyeuse oui bah ce soit oui bah une
jeune femme a tiqué à mettre ses sorties
dans les nouvelles ce matin une jeune
femme attikameks sa fille comme un même
temps dans le document parle c'est 1,5
en fin de partie 2 2 acquis mais ouais
c'est ça une jeune femme attikameks qui
est victime de propos racistes
quand elle veut jouer au hockey dans la
ville de par exemple de saint félicien
donc oui ça c'est les propos à nuancer
comme une autre manifestation a fait du
racisme puis pour revenir un peu sur la
différence entre assises discrimination
de race c'est plus une question de
radiologie et attitudes de mentalité et
la discrimation sait plus comment ça se
manifeste dans nos comportements donc la
discrimination en fête d'école à la
discrimination raciale par exemple
découle de réagir sinon c'est quand même
un temps interdit louis we may était là
vous êtes vous êtes à waswanipi mais
sinon vous êtes aussi ailleurs un peu
partout sur le territoire
est ce que le racisme envers vous envers
votre communauté ou les communautés en
général sont plus fréquentes en région
ou en milieu urbain je dirais que c'est
moitié moitié et moi j'habitais à
montréal laval et gendrey subi j'en ai
suivi de son nez subi des comportements
racistes puis moi j'étais j'ai témoigné
d'ailleurs à la commission vient comme
ça contre des services policiers en trop
qui moi bon je suis déménagé dans ma
communauté
surtout pas en fait pour éviter puis je
pense aussi que à montréal ça prenait
une forme un peu plus un peu plus
insidieusement sont tous quand j'étais
invité à donner des présentations dans
des écoles les choses comme ça où les
gens me demandaient de farces médiévales
ma de faire l'éducation d'aider à propos
des peuples autochtones bénévolement je
pense que c'est qu'ils me paient moins
que nos personnes qu'ils évitent ce je
pense que j'ai envie aux gens vivaient
beaucoup puis à un moment donné bon cgt
un peu le toqué ça prend une personne
mais si c'est pour ça en fait que je
suis amené à jouer dessus des raisons
pourquoi je suis re déménagé en
communauté parce que j'avais pu je
n'avais plus envie d'expliquer ma
culture mon origine tout le temps puis
je voulais la vivre ma culture au lieu
de l'a2 au lieu de l'expliquer puis donc
si ça donc je voulais ça que je suis
donc tissé serré comporte en date avec
qui elle est avec ses fans c'est pour ça
que je suis revenue mais je dirais qu'en
région bon peut-être que ça prend ça
prend deux formes mesuré que je dirais
que c'est la même chose alors en tout
cas j'espère que vous n'étiez pas
sollicité bénévolement pour travailler
aux capsules que vous avez préparé en
lien avec eux briser le code parce qu'il
ya le documentaire briser le code il ya
un balado je pense et il ya aussi des
capsules auquel plusieurs personnes ont
participé dont vous vous en avez préparé
trois ou quatre ans je les ai noté l'un
géré par des couacs
jean des trois ans que j'anime moi même
puis j'en ai j'en ai une autre
les trois animateurs voilà alors une
entre autres qui s'appelle
l'appropriation culturelle donc
démystifier un peu c'est quoi le concept
d'appropriation culturel
il ya aussi les biais inconscient donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des biens
consent inconscient et comment on
devrait les reconnaître et puis il ya
autochtone 102 la 70 tonnes 100 m
autochtone 110-102 parce que vous pensez
que déjà les gens connaissent un petit
peu sur les autochtones mais c'est juste
qu'on devrait être en juin je pense que
je pense qu'on devrait être en mesure de
moi moi j'attends que les gens ne
pensent pas que je paie pas de taxes
partout n'importe quand je pense que la
fatigue je pense que la sphère des taxes
la faire des démos comédiens sport qui
en en eux je pense qu'on en a parlé
beaucoup piste est un peu je pense donc
pas militant c'est une frustration le
convie fréquemment devoir expliquer ces
concepts simples à outrance
nous on a un où on assume que c'est déjà
enregistré de toute façon il ya eu
amplement d'informations disponibles là
dessus sur internet dans les journaux
het volk nous on a décidé de faire un
peu d'aller un peu plus loin
alors je vais juste faire un petit
commentaire est dommage par continent
quelques outils incontournables dont
espace autochtones parce qu'on montre
les ressources auxquelles on peut se
référer pour aller voir pour en
apprendre plus sur les autochtones et
c'est dommage j'ai pas vu et pitt ing
pas vu si be seen d'aedgency bixente
j'ai pas vu espace autochtones qui sont
quand même des ressources vraiment une
mine d'informations sur des réalités
autochtones en apprendre plus alors
voilà c'était mon petit commentaire mais
sinon oui les capsules est ce que vous
allez en faire d'autres est-ce qu'il y
en a déjà trois qui en aura plus que ça
moi c'est tout ce qu'on m'a demandé le
les télés les capsules moi je sais je
sais plus et qui a écrit les textes et
on les a révisé chacun nous les a
remises et les adapter
et par la suite mais n'ont pour le
moment et c'était tout j'espère en faire
d'autres si j'avais eu l'opportunité se
présente je me laisserais excellente en
plus une passion vous les avez fait avec
beaucoup d'humour ce qu'yves dédramatise
aussi le sujet parce que c'est des
sujets qui ne sont pas évidents et le
faire passer avec humour
c'est peut-être une façon idéale aussi
pour aller atteindre les gens exactement
pied nous on voulait on voulait cibler
un auditoire qui est assez jeunes aussi
qui c'est pour ça qu'on est allé à
autochtone sans doute parce que je pense
qu'elle est je pense que la plus jeune
génération sont plus sensibles à ces
questions là on apprenne un petit peu
plus à l'école même si bon c'est le
curry a même pas encore parfait mais on
s'entend que je pense que dans ce sens
ils en apprennent plus que la génération
donc c'est pour ça et je pense qu'elles
lui mots comme vous
une belle façon désamorcer quelque chose
de mieux faire passer un message aussi
et ils vont vous avez vu les capsules il
ya beaucoup d'aidé dedans on insère des
segments qui sont drôles on a laissé les
vidéos donc c'est super nancy pas que ce
parcours donc si jamais la laisser
briser les feux nous encouragent
oui elles sont très très bien fait ces
capsules absolument donc elles sont
disponibles sur le site de télé québec
ça vaut vraiment la peine d'aller
d'aller les consulter parlons des jeunes
justement est ce que les jeunes ont
intégré déjà le code oui dia oui les
jeunes autochtones parce que alexandre
volant en parler lui dis bon ben moi
j'ai brisé le code maintenant on le voit
dans le documentaire il dit maintenant
j'ai envie d'aller parler aux jeunes
pour leur dire elle ne tombait pas là
dedans
ouais ben je pense que je peux pas
parler pour tous les jeunes mais je
pense quand même effectivement
envie je pense un peu tous à différents
niveaux qui certaines personnes vont
peut-être avoir tous besoin de ces
mécanismes de défense pour se protéger
justement des gens qui vivent comme des
puces de racisme de discrimination que
ça vaut peut-être développer un peu plus
ces mécanismes parce que ce sont des en
fait des mécanismes de défense
bien sûr mais protection aussi on se
protège
ouais c'est ça mais mes stats us f1 en
fait deux pour commencer de renverser
tous appuyé de se dire que comme moi des
fois j'essaie de me dire qui j'aimerais
ça comme un peu pour faire dispose sur
ce qu'il m'a utilisé comme je me suis
passé plus de temps à aimer ma culture
et mon peuple et mimi confrères mes
concerts qui est de passer du temps à
détester le racisme et le colonialisme
puis ses sept enfants
je pense que moyen de contrer tous en
fait le coach et deux assesseurs
d'essayer de valoriser sa culture de
travail
revaloriser son identité je pense que
les jeunes autochtones sont aussi très
inventif à ce niveau besson
parce qu'en fait une culture c'est ça a
évolué avec le temps qui je pense que
les joueurs docteur son site web
bien placé pour pouvoir justement
réinventer puis faire évoluer les
cultures autochtones je pense elle a dit
aussi qu'il faut se concentrer pour
essayer de trouver le code oui est-ce
que avec mick hannah est ce que c'est ce
que vous faites
oui ben en fait une des grandes
facilités de mécano c'est d'appliquer
justement déjà un autochtone dans
l'éducation sur la santé de la faune sur
les réalités autochtones puis on essaie
en même temps ben justement que ce soit
pour les jeunes autochtones
une manière de valoriser nos histoires
de mariée de faire un peu de l'âme
permettent en fait parce que pas
seulement comme éduqués pour indiquer où
il était important 6 pour ne pas se
faire ce travail de comment vous le
faites et concrètement donnez moi des
exemples éviter que vous organisez on a
même beaucoup des ateliers mais qui vont
au delà des ateliers disons classique de
magistrale
on essaye beaucoup de femmes des
ateliers interactifs pierre en a un que
j'ai eu ben j'avais eu la chance
notamment de commencer à la prendre
quand j'étais chez les femmes
autochtones du québec et c'est un jeu de
rôle qui s'appelle le circuit la boîte
dans lesquelles les gens elle joue un
rôle dans une société autochtone
précoloniale dans le cercle puis à la
fin de l'atelier comme une narration sur
l'histoire la colonisation et à la fin
ça se termine encore et donc avec le
système des conseils de bande puis la
manière occidentale de
de fonctionnement et donc c'est comme
trouver d'autres moyens de celui de deux
cent se disent les gens qui lancent
aussi un peu plus passé sera interactif
puisse inspirer aussi de nos cultures
histoire et ça ce sont des ateliers qui
s'adresse aux autochtones aux jeunes
autochtones
en fait les deux en fait le au début
le la mission c'était d'éduquer des
adducteurs nos réalités d'octobre mais
on s'est rendu compte aussi que les
jeunes autochtones avaient envie aussi
de se réapproprier le résume donc
finalement on en même temps les deux
milieux mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant majoritairement c'est beaucoup
auprès des publics allochtone qui ont
beaucoup d'ignorance par rapport aux
réalités au dr oui oui oui alors vous
m'aidiez à votre votre jeune enfant en
fait est votre enfant ali tout jeune
donc on ne sait pas comment elle va
vivre dans la société à quoi ça va
ressembler mans va se tourner vers
isabelle parce qu'isabelle à des
adolescents des adolescents et des
adolescents ou et de garou isabelle est
ce que vos adolescents sont tombés dans
le code des skis ou alors est ce qu'ils
ont appris justement à ne pas à ne pas
tomber dans cette façon de faire je vais
parler plutôt de nos plus vieux l'autre
est encore assez jeune mais
effectivement à l'école ils veulent dans
une école hors communauté et il a été
victime de racisme on va se le dire
et pendant un bout de temps bienvenue
moment donné un soir il était en
secondaire 2 juillet d'une maman je
n'aurais jamais dû dire que je suis mort
qu et ça a été pour une maman ça a été
extrêmement difficile alors on en a
énormément parlé puis on s'est dit bon
comment est ce qu'on fait à partir de
maintenant parce que là il s'est dit
plus jamais je vais parler de ce qui se
passe dans l'actualité ou que je vais
démontrer un élément culturel
en fait c'est ce qui est en train de me
dire si je vais me fondre dans la masse
ça va être facile ils vont arrêter mais
qui aurait pu me dérangeait ah oui ça
c'est le fameux code là on est en
allemand on est en plein dedans alors
j'ai dit est ce que c'est ce qu'il faut
faire
j'ai réfléchi moi même parce que quand
ça t'arrive atwan vrai que tu réagi de
manière instinctive mais quand tu dois
donner des conseils il faut quand même
réfléchir à tout ça et j'ai réalisé à
quel point briser le code demandait de
l'assurance demandaient du courage parce
que briser le code c'est en fait
justement à être soi-même socioculturel
mans parlant entre autres et ça dans une
société qui n'est pas la tienne sa
demande et nord
mais man de courage et quand tu es
fatigué quant à paul goût on a ou les
mécanismes de défense dont on parlait
tout à l'heure et de protection qui va
faire en sorte que justement on veut se
forme au [ __ ] laisse à jouer la game
quand j'étais plus jeune ou se fondre
dans le moule
avant d'appeler ça le code mais je
trouve ça très intéressant cette notion
du colosse c'est tout à fait juste
alors alors j'ai réfléchi avec mon grand
et je sais que tranquillement il
commence à faire les choses il trouvait
peut-être l'humour c'est un moyen pour
nous pour lui d'amener les choses
autrement
on ne fait je suis même allé à l'école
pour donner un atelier c'est pour
sensibiliser les autochtones sont
heureux parce qu'on aimait encore le on
essaie de faire ce qu'il faut pour que
et le mont jeune noah puisse s'épanouir
dans son école mais c'est un travail de
tous les instants il va devoir vivre
avec ça toute sa vie et prendre les
positions avec lesquels il se sent bien
je pense que l'important c'est ce je
pense qu'il va pouvoir savoir que moment
donné oui il peut pousser la barrière un
peu plus loin puis d'autres fois s'il
sent pas il faut qu'ils se respectent la
dent puis qui qui qui qui se donne un
moment pour lui je pense que c'est ce
qui est important au bout de ligne oui
alors là je vous vois toutes les trois
vous travaillé très fort pour briser le
code
maintenant faisons travailler les autres
les non autochtones qu'est ce qu'ils
doivent faire comme travail pour ne pas
vous imposer un code pour briser le code
existant
je vais tendre le micro peut-être en
premier à maïté mon dieu moi je pense et
je pense que professionnellement moi je
me suis refait à boubers comme je sais
pas trop le fait que j'étais pays - qui
aide aux personnes qui n'étaient pas
très fun je pense que ç'a déjà
reconnaître reconnaître
le savoir les compétences même si tu es
bon versus quelqu'un qui versus
quelqu'un qui qui est tout à fait le
tour des études en déduit du citadis vie
dans ma culture l'histoire familiale
je pense que jean bon jeu mais même si
j'ai pas de chez pas de diplôme qui
atteste ce jeu j'ai des connaissances il
sauva la puissa je pense que ces
reconnaissances cette reconnaissance lui
ça va surtout en milieu urbain après bon
moi c'est sûr que c'est sûr qu'il ya des
fois aussi
moi je reçois beaucoup bond je reçois
beaucoup de choses sur les médias
sociaux des courriels instagram de gens
qui me demandant aux orres une histoire
un vendredi si je peux leur expliquer
aussi je peux les aider pour l'heure
leurs devoirs des universités je pense
que exiger des moyens beaucoup de choses
que j'ai apprises en faisant de la
lecture je ne suis pas née sachant tout
ce que je connais aujourd'hui je pense
que ça c'est important de respecter de
nous respecter en tant qu' en tant
qu'autochtones et bon moment il ya un
moment pour lui demander des choses
aussi mais si je peux pas aider tout le
monde qu'ils demandent de les aider pour
faire leurs devoirs
mes fils et s'est vue parce que c'est
important qu'ils lisent aussi yeux
tellement jeu de bbc radio 4
je sors toujours des listes de bons
livres d'auteurs et d'artistes
autochtones décrire autochtone à lire et
y est tellement de ressources maintenant
en ligne
je pense que c'est je pense que
peut-être que ça force à travers aussi
le curriculum scolaire d'encourager la
littérature d'encourager de d'encore
d'encore changer ce que le jeu doit lier
papa quand même s'il ya eu un groupe un
groupe que travailler là dessus il ya
quelques années puis oublié de laisser
leurs formulaires le curriculum n'est
pas encore parfait puis je pense que je
pense qu il
et je pense que le gouvernement devrait
devrait nous tendre la main et encore un
peu plus puisque vers souvent le sial
poste la peau coffret des râles parce
qu'ils vont y dix ans les autochtones ce
une conférence et une compétence
fédérale de toute façon mais je pense
qu'on se sous-estiment le pouvoir des
provinces là dedans je pense que bon je
pense que ça serait déjà à l'épreuve
voilà alors je vois l'immédiat prendre
des notes je vais la laisser continuer à
prendre c'est notre on va se tourner
vers isabelle isabelle les non
autochtones qu'est ce qu'ils doivent
faire comme travail de leur côté mais
j'entendais maïté tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'elle dit mais ce que je
réalisais aussi ses cours delà de sa
houppette apparemment de tout ça c'est
qu'ils doivent déjà reconnaître qu'il y
ait un code et ça ce n'est pas fait je
pense pour l'ensemble des non
autochtones justement venant ici à
luanda qui je m'en venais avec un ami
qui lui et non autochtone et on
discutait de l'appropriation culturelle
de racisme ou demander qu'est-ce que je
m'en venais faire à l'émission et on
discutait de ce fameux code là et il ne
le voyais pas ou à peine donc déjà de
réfléchir à la question je pense que ça
va amener une certaine ouverture de
mieux comprendre les choses
et peut-être que par la suite pour vos
pouvoirs justement
et le jeu quand je dis on je parle des
non autochtones mais tranquillement
laissé l'espace le briser ce fameux code
là en intégrant bon peu importe où on
est mais en laissant les autres êtres
qu'ils sont que socioculturel m'en parle
notamment ainsi c'est à l'intérieur des
gouvernements mais pensez aussi aux
autochtones dans tout ce qui est fait
donc il ya plusieurs manières de fermer
l'ouverture bien sûr et comme on le
disait le racisme par un peu de
l'ignorance donc bien seul antidote
c'est l'éducation et la sensibilisation
l'information je pense que c'est
essentiel oui dia c'est que la grande
question quand c'est tout le temps posé
mais en fait je pense que dans ce
contexte particulièrement il ya quand
même un aspect écoute est considérée qui
est important
écoutez les autochtones qu'est-ce qu'il
veut vider croire aussi parce que sinon
il ya cette tendance à les croire ou
peut-être minimiser banalisée
qu'est-ce qui vais mais je pense est
important d'être à l'écouté c'est pas
parce que personnellement du pas de la
discrimination du racisme qu'une autre
personne enlevée fait je pense qu'un
aspect écoute vraiment important un
aspect autour réflexion aussi à savoir
comment et bien que ce soit qu'on peut
contribuer justement à ce code ne te
faire porter bon ce responsabilité là à
briser les codes à ce qu'ils vivent
sinon ben bombe à la même chose que ce
qu'isabelle puma et et 18,5 formé puis
est différente manière de s'informer je
passais importante encore une fois pas
faire porter le poids de l'éducation et
la sensibilisation sur des individus
dans le monde
en vieillissant de passer 30 dans son
quotidien à éduquer sur les questions
autochtones est ce qu'on le fait de me
canoy parce que c'est pour fourguer des
organistes qu'il fasse parce que chaque
individu autochtone pas envie plus
chaque individu et pas seulement experts
de toutes les questions d'une donne
seulement deux repas québécois bon soit
un expert de la politique la géographie
des ors de la jeunesse québécoise qui va
parler de tout ça donc
ce serait arrêter de faire porter ses
poils aux individus autochtone et
d'aller soi-même maintenant avec
internet c'est facile d'aller informer
sur les questions autochtones
vous l'avez mentionné tantôt avec tout
les médias maintenant et pitié un espace
autochtone ces piscines de jeunesse mais
aussi passer ça la littérature
autochtone ce n'est pas en fermant à les
lire des livres d'histoire minute
suivante manière d'aller assez
sensibilisés aux questions autochtones
puis non son ballet où c'était une
petite coche un peu plus loin le
vraiment y réfléchir comment au-delà de
ma forme et comment je peux être allié
son audit autochtone les réseaux
autochtone de montréal ont créé un outil
intéressant justement c'est comment est
ralliée aux lieux autochtone puis fin de
rides en fait il existe un guide sur la
question bien sûr mais il ya peu de
doute c'est très simple maintenant avec
tout ça les recommandations des
commissions il ya vraiment moyen de
trouver des pièces de cette absolument
absolument d'ailleurs je le mentionne on
va bientôt recevoir pierre lepage pour
parler de mythes et réalités autochtones
ça aussi c'est un ouvrage il existe en
ligne maintenant qu'on devrait consulter
on se dit mais je connais pas voilà
voilà une ressource qui va me permettre
d'apprendre les réalités autochtones
voilà un merci tout les trois vraiment
ça a été très agréable de vous recevoir
j'en profite pour dire que maïté écrit
dans le journal métro des chroniques qui
sont toujours très inspiré ça aussi
c'est une façon de décoloniser les
esprits des gens alors je les invite à
continuer à vous lire dans le métro
merci beaucoup ma été labrecque saganash
hugo très très agréable que vous ayez
accepté cette invitation et puis bonne
chance pour la suite merci merci à
isabelle qui est à québec isabelle qui
chronique aussi pour le journal la
presse
un là aussi c'est important d'aller lire
sommes toutes vos réflexions qui sont
importantes sur des enjeux importants
des autochtones d'ailleurs est ce que
vous le voyez les commentaires des
lecteurs de la presse est ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'ils sont à l'écouté
de ce que vous dites a tellement
tellement je rencontre des gens tout le
temps qu'ils viennent me voir puis on
aime ce que ce que on aime ça vous
entendre laissant entendre une voix
autochtone
c'est extrêmement motivant pour
continuer parce que c'est pas toujours
facile de parler des sujets disons
complexes que sont les enjeux
autochtones
oui voila merci beaucoup isabelle on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine merci et
puis merci à vous il ya la rivière donc
mikana on se tourne vers vous amis cana
pour en apprendre plus sur les réalités
autochtones aussi merci merci infiniment
la semaine prochaine tiens je vous le
dis tout de suite on va s'intéresser au
regroupement des centres d'amitié
autochtones il existe depuis 50 ans un
peu partout dans des des villes à
travers la province
il ya un centre d'amitié autochtone à
montréal entre autres donc nous allons
en parler
le 7 février sur espace autochtone en
direct à tous merci et bonne semaine
[Musique]